[موسيقى]
كان ابوه قبطان بحريا لكنه عشق كره القدم
تمتع رجب طيب اردوغان بموهبه كرويه لافته
في الاعداديه والثانويه لعب لصالح نادي
جامع الرياضي مقابل الف ليره شهريا اطلق
عليه اصدقائه لقب الامام بيكنباور كابورا
ونمت مهاراته وتلقى عروضا من انديه اسكي
وفنر بهجه لكن والده عارض الامر
بدات في الرابعه عشر بلعب كره القدم في
الحي كنت وقتها طالبا في المرحله الثانويه
وكنت اتدرب في اكاديميه اسطنبول لكره
القدم ايضا بعد الانتهاء من المدرسه حاولت
دخول كليه التربيه الرياضيه واحتراف كره
القدم لكن والدي رحمه الله اعترض ومنعني
من اجل اكمال الدراسه ولم اتمكن من احتراف
كره القدم
منافسه في الانتخابات كمال كلجدار اوغلو
ولد بمنطقه ريفيه شرق الاناضول لعائله
علويه كان والده موظفا حكوميا فسار على
سير ابيه عمل محاسبا ثم تدرج في الوظائف
الحكوميه الى ان اصبح رئيسا لمؤسسه الضمان
الاجتماعي ساقت الاقدار الرجلين من عالم
الرياضه والوظيفه الى دهاليز السياسه حتى
المنافسه على رئاسه تركيا
[تصفيق]
ومع ذلك ما زال اردوغان لا يفوت فرصه الا
واظهر فيها مهاراته الرياضيه كذلك
الذي نشر صوره في المطبخ كموظف عادي يساعد
زوجته في الاعمال المنزليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات